Creator Robert Kirkman is finally ready to
talk about what caused the fictional zombie
pandemic in The Walking Dead.
For fans who have been following the story
of The Walking Dead since Rick Grimes first
awoke from his coma back in 2003, this revelation
is a long time coming.
It's actually impressive that Kirkman has
kept his cards so close to his vest for so
long considering the franchise has expanded
to infect every quadrant of our media world:
video games, books, TV you name it.
Now, having reached the epic conclusion of
his long-running tale, at least in comic form,
Kirkman must have decided it was finally time
to dole out a little fan service.
Early on in the comic series, it's revealed
that every human in the world is already infected
with the zombie pathogen; while zombie bites
accelerate the transformation, any death eventually
results in zombification.
We've seen survivors navigate every facet
of this deadly scenario without any understanding
of the zombie horde's origins.
Well, wonder no more.
On Twitter, Kirkman finally confirmed that
the cause of this pandemic is extraterrestrial
in nature.
"Aliens."
Specifically, the zombie virus came from a
"space spore," in Kirkman's own words.
Kirkman has long credited the work of the
late horror movie director George A. Romero
as a key inspiration for The Walking Dead.
He's said on numerous occasions that his entire
magnum opus resulted from the question, "What
if a zombie movie just kept going?"
In light of this, the space spore explanation
may be yet another homage to Romero particularly
his iconic zombie flick Night of the Living
Dead, wherein the zombie apocalypse has potentially
been instigated by radiation released from
a space probe to Venus.
"That's the space vehicle which orbited Venus
and then was purposefully destroyed by NASA
when scientists discovered it was carrying
a mysterious high-level radiation."
Fans weren't sure they'd ever get a straight
answer from Kirkman as to what started the
zombie virus in The Walking Dead.
In a 2018 Q&A on Tumblr, he dismissed the
notion of revealing the source of the zombie
contagion as irrelevant to the story, saying:
"Maybe years after it's all over I'll just
casually mention it in an interview.
That seems like a very J.K.
Rowling thing to do."
Shots fired!
Fortunately for curious fans, it seems like
Kirkman found his inner Rowling.
On the surface, it may not seem like Kirkman's
earthbound tale of humans surviving against
impossible odds has much to do with extraterrestrials,
but the alien explanation has always been
bubbling around the edges of The Walking Dead.
When Kirkman and his creative team originally
pitched the idea to Image Comics, Kirkman
had to concoct an outlandish backstory for
the series just to catch executives' attention.
At that time, he told a substantial white
lie that the zombie pandemic in The Walking
Dead was designed by aliens who intended to
use the zombie apocalypse to make Earth a
softer target for invasion.
Although Kirkman was pretty clear that this
was never really his team's intention, it
wasn't the last mention of E.T.'s in The Walking
Dead history.
While not necessarily canon, a bonus ending
for issue #75 was inspired by this misleading
pitch.
In this sci-fi re-skin, a lightsaber-wielding
Michonne explains that hostile aliens unleashed
the zombie horde to turn humanity into a race
of slaves bound into service by harvesting
water, which their alien overlords use as
currency.
How's that for an alternate ending?
Aside from the explanation of the virus being
"totally irrelevant" to the comic series,
Kirkman also believes that the TV iterations
of his work are unlikely to explore either
the source of or cure for the virus.
While certain fans may prefer a pat resolution
to the apocalypse plaguing the world of The
Walking Dead, Kirkman's instincts are probably
spot-on.
The third TV series for the franchise, The
Walking Dead: World Beyond, takes place a
decade after the beginning of the zombie pandemic,
with a set of young protagonists still grappling
with the world of the undead.
"The end of the world was our beginning."
The lack of a cure is definitely organic to
Kirkman's original vision.
The Walking Dead has never been a series about
finding a miraculous cure it's a story about
survivors re-establishing a new normal in
a world that will never be the same.
Discovering a cure would undermine the entire
premise.
But hey, at least we officially know what
started the collapse in the first place.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.